[Music]
nissi nash and her wife jessica betts
are making her story covering the march
april 2022 black women in hollywood
issue of essence they're the first time
same-sex couple to ever do so baby
essence magazine has stood the test of
what time
here are the cover stars packing on the
pda and posing topless showing off that
undeniable chemistry as nisi looks
straight to the camera as jessica
lovingly cradles her face we are better
together
we are far better together so everything
we do is easier because we're a real
team
in another photo the two stunned in
matching blue numbers both looking
fierce as ever big question is how did
the couple prepare our pre-shoot ritual
is to pray before and have cocktails
after
boom
and who took longer to get ready
[Music]
it was well worth the wait for the looks
and the whole making history thing
what i am hoping
happens with our cover
is that
it will normalize
people just loving who they love
and not having to
explain it or defend it
but just do it
absolutely spreading love and supporting
each other you know um women you know
it's it's a beautiful thing to be able
to support each other and so not just in
love but just in general so i think this
message is very clear
that we should love and support each
other regardless of our race gender or
sexuality
there's no doubt neesee and jessica are
doing just that ever since tying the
knot back in august 2020 and turns out
their love story was an unexpected one
we were really really good friends and i
loved her as a person
there was no doubt about that she loved
me too but i never thought about a
relationship with her or any other woman
for that matter of fact and then
after i was divorced i don't know what
happened i looked at her one day and my
eyes crossed and i said who are you
okay and can you sit and stay awhile
[Laughter]
this marks nisi's third marriage she was
previously married to don nash from 1994
to 2007 and jay tucker from 2011 to 2019
but it seems like third time's a charm
when etie spoke with a claw star
following her and jessica's first
anniversary she couldn't help but gush
about her wife it's the greatest love of
my life so far
this is it i mean i i haven't
experienced love like this and
you know i say
for me
the best part about it is being fully
seen i am
so happy
i i i can't imagine being any
any place with anyone
other than jb i don't i don't i don't
see it
[Music]
you